He was a comic genius.
You had only one speed setting and that
was full throttle for he burst into our
lives as an alien on happy days.
He amazed us with his range of talents.
It's utterly left us breathless.
Yes,
behind the stick of Robin Williams
was a man who was deeply play,
goodbye depression.
He had other demons such as
alcohol and cocaine as well.
Still,
he kept us entertained to the variant,
which made it all the more unfathomable
to his legion of fans and admires me.
Took his life at the age of 63.
In today's biographics,
we intend to get the essence
of the real Robin Williams.
Robin mcclaren Williams came
into the welds on July the 23rd,
1951 board at Saint Luke's
Hospital in Chicago,
Illinois.
He was the only child of
Laurie and Robert Williams.
The family was wealthy with Robert to
being a senior executive at the Ford Motor
Company.
Laurie was a full model
and two part time actress.
Lots of Robin's formative years were
spent a loan in the huge mention that was
his home.
In order to cope with his loneliness,
he created characters and
conversations in his head.
He was an overweight child which
lead to bullying at school.
Sixth grade,
he later recalled was the most
difficult year of his life.
Many days he went to crying after
constant name calling and physical
harassments.
Each day was torment for
him with his only friends,
being the ones he created
in his own imagination,
these difficult 20 years.
They brought on a depression that robin
was to grapple with for the rest of his
life.
Robin began by using comedy
as a defense mechanism.
It started with his mother.
Lori had a very sharp wit and we'd often
use humor and laced with sarcasm to
communicate with her son in
order to connect with that.
Robin Hanson make his mother laugh.
It wasn't good enough to be Robin.
He had to be funny Robin,
by the time he was 16,
the family had relocated to California
where Robin attended redwood high school.
It was the late sixties and the straight
laced robin found himself in the middle
of a counter culture that
revolved around drugs and sex.
He was able to loosen up on
after dabbling with marijuana,
found himself fitting
in for the first time.
It was at redwood high that Robin,
he stumbled upon the drama department.
He had already perfected his comedic
vanilla quickly establishing a reputation
as the class clown.
He felt totally in love with the
idea of Improv performance is comedic
personality slowly emerging
through drama classes.
At the same time,
robin got involved in wrestling and
soccer proving to be an accomplished
athlete.
Bonds by the time he graduated in 1969,
he was voted by his classmates
as least likely to succeed.
Not surprisingly though,
he was also voted funniest students.
After graduating,
he attended Claremont
men's college is sites.
They were set on a career in
political science before long,
however,
he was spending more time in the college
theater when he was in lecture rims.
He won the coveted role of Fagan and the
college is production of Oliver Turning
in a performance that made it clear that
he was destined for the limelight even
behind his diplomatic ambitions.
Robin involved in a community
college has a program during classes.
See what often improvised
living as classmates and
teachers in fits of laughter.
After three years of honing his craft,
he was offered the opportunity of a
lifetime full of scholarship or to the
Julliard School of Performing
Arts in New York City.
Robin was one of only two
students accepted into the
1973 advanced program that
juilliard the other.
While that was future Superman
Christopher Reeve rave,
who would become a close friend,
recalled his first impressions.
Upon meeting Williams,
he wore a tie dye shirts with tracksuit
bottoms and talked to Marla minutes.
I'd never seen so much energy
contained in one person.
He was like an Untied Balloon that had
been inflated and immediately released.
I watched in horror as he virtually
chromed off the walls of the class and
hallways.
To say that he was on would
be a major understatement.
The juilliard.
Well Robin,
the heat astounded his teachers
and fellow students alike.
He was able to take on epicenter
of characters with ease,
trading out one accent
or dialect for another,
like he was born to do it,
but with the Robin,
he was frustrated at juilliard.
He just didn't fit in.
After two years,
his teachers told him that there was
nothing more that they could teach him.
One of his instructors
considered robin's via genius.
He was not being properly served by
schools conservative in its classical
training style.
He left juilliard in 1976 to
launch himself onto the world.
His first stop was the standup
circuit on the west coast.
Robin's first break into
the realms of comedy.
Okay.
Mr. Club in the San Francisco Bay area,
his first Gig was it the holy city zoo,
where he also spent time tending bar.
These early sides.
They were frantic,
bordering on psychotic.
No one had ever seen anything
quite like Robin Williams.
He played a collection of
rather edgy characters,
including reverend oral
satisfaction is only standup,
was influenced by the likes of Lenny Bruce
Peter Sellers and Jonathan winters is
manage quickfire Adlib
routines and off the wall,
physical comedy proved an absolute
hit anti soon established.
A loyal following.
Robin loves the immediate feedback that
came with standup comedy and it was
something that he would continue right
through his career despite the apparent
ease of his performances.
He actually found stand up incredibly
stressful underneath the cloak of exact.
He wants an intensely shy man.
He once said that he started using drugs
and alcohol as a crutch to combat stage
nuts in 1977 when he moved to Los Angeles
where he began performing if a comedy
club.
It was here that he was discovered
by TV producer George Schlatter,
who offered him a spot in a
revival of the old sixties show.
Often now the show,
well,
it ultimately didn't survive,
but for Williams it established a
foothold into a career in television.
He became,
they send me regular cast member on the
Richard Pryor show while also continuing
perform standup.
It was an appearance on
the Richard Pryor show,
the brought Williams to the
attention of Gary Marshall,
the producer of the hit Sitcom,
happy days,
often five years.
This scripture,
it says,
while they were running out of ideas they,
they hadn't yet jumped the shark.
They decided to do an episode taking
off the 19 sixties Scifi comedy.
My favorite Martian,
the episode when it was called my favorite
organ and it called for the costing
of an access to play an alien from the
land of Org Marshall Thought Williams
might be the man for the job in one has
gone down as possibly the most brilliant
audition in TV history,
rubbing into the room and immediately
sat in the chair on his hat.
He continued to do his lines and then
broken Zune inspired Adlib Marshall.
It cost him on the spot.
Later commenting that Williams was the
only alien who turned up for the part the
episode of happy days.
It was originally shot is a dream
sequence on the part of Richie Cunningham.
However,
the character played by Williams mork
from ork was such a hit with the TV
watching audience after an initial
broadcast that the ending was refilled.
So mark was a real character.
Once your Robbins' work on the happy
days episode was improvised and augmented
with physical comedy,
audiences couldn't get enough of the
Zany adient and demanded much more.
This led to the creation
of the spinoff series,
Mork and mindy,
which ran from 1978 to 1982.
The show catapulted,
Williams do absolute
started literally overnight.
After just two weeks on the APP.
It had zoomed to the top
10 of the Nielsen Ratings,
the producers of the show.
They kept the script to loose enough to
give robin plenty of room to do as he
pleased,
and the results were unpredictable
over the top until areas.
While the critics,
they weren't overly
enthused with the show,
they went absolutely falling over
themselves to lavish praise upon it.
Star
woke up and it quickly became
a pop culture phenomenon.
A generation of kids took to warring
mark's Trademark Rainbow suspenders and
greeting their friends with the words no,
no.
Robin went from relative obscurity to
instant fame in the space of a couple of
months.
It was something that he was entirely
unprepared for and unfortunately it led to
him indulging in the
accessories that come with fame,
drugs,
alcohol and women.
Just Nike acted in the fast lane.
He also lived his life and
the fastest of fast names.
He quickly slipped into the habit
of partying into the early hours,
crawling home at five in the morning,
and then having to be on set by 10:00 AM.
There is no doubt though,
that Robin,
he was blessed with more physical
energy than most inevitably.
However,
that energy began to burn out.
He would sometimes fall asleep on the set.
We'll just sit a dormancy in off mode.
One night after performing a
late night set at a comedy club,
robin met up with fellow
comic John Belushi and ended
up at the Chateau Marmont
where Robin's shared some
of blue she's cocaine,
and then left the next day on
the set of Mork and Mindy Costar.
Pam dawber broke the news to Williams
knew she had died of a drug overdose.
The news well that shot him into making
significant changes in his lifestyle.
The death of Belushi tarnish the image
of Hollywood's fastest living brass pack.
Robyn was called to testify before a
grand jury and experience which along with
the shock of Belushi's death and
the birth of his first child,
Zach allows him to break free from the
strangle hold of drugs and alcohol.
It was at this time that he discovered
cycling a form of exercise which you
credits for saving his life.
After four years,
Mork and mindy had lost its midas touch,
produces dried whatever they could
to resurrect the initial appeal,
but nothing seemed to work.
They decided to make more,
less naive,
allowing Williams to work in more
of his nightclub act material.
Interestingly,
the more character and also founded
sway into his standup routines,
though not by Robin's design
audience members at late night shows,
we'd simply yell out,
do more,
switch Robinwood,
frustratingly responds,
or mark's not here.
I'm a different guy.
By the middle of 1982,
though,
the character that had propelled Williams
to superstar status was beginning to
feel like a millstone around his neck,
so it came as somewhat of a relief to
him when mork and mindy was canceled.
After Four Seasons
in 1976,
robin,
Ms Valerie Velarde while working
as a bartender in San Francisco.
Shortly after leaving Julliard,
she was a dancer having
studied at Julliard herself
or they began a relationship
that ends after two years were
married on June the fourth,
19,
78.
Valerie,
she endured husbands,
cocaine addiction,
and wild partying lifestyle
for a number of years,
as we mentioned the among other things,
it was the birth of his son
Zachary on April the 11th,
1983 that have led him to
finally shake off his addictions,
our thought that was one thing that he
was not able to control that that was his
wondering.
I ended up having an affair with a
cocktail waitress by the name of Michelle.
Tish caught up then in 1986 ms dot
[inaudible] sued Williams for six point
$4,000,000,
painting that he had knowingly
infected with herpes simplex virus.
He settled out of course only for his
wife to see if a divorce a few months
later on April the 30th,
1999,
less than a year after his divorce
from Valerie being finalized.
Williams married last year.
Grimes,
the form of [inaudible] 92.
His son Zach,
they had actually been carrying on
an affair during the last few years.
It was a previous marriage,
but at the time of the wedding last
year was pregnant with Robin's trials,
a daughter who they named Zelda Ray.
Two years later,
they had a second child,
cody Allen,
the marriage.
It lasted 19 years,
but Mysia finally left after she realized
she wasn't able to handle Robin's
relapse into addiction Williams.
He married for the third
and final time in 2011.
This wants to Susan Schneider,
who was a graphic designer at the time.
He met her while recovering
from a heart operation in 2009.
They were still together at
the time of his death in 2014
robin's fame on the small screen.
It's inevitably arouse the
interest of movie makers.
His first starring role came 19 eighties,
Popeye,
the maybe it was a financial amped,
critical flop mentally
like Williams is film.
Korea was over before it
took really gotten started,
but then in 1982 years,
the world,
according to Garp,
he was able to show more of
his dramatic acting talents.
The film,
it was well received with Chris
Abbott Calling Robin's performance
unconventional and absorbing,
following a couple of smaller roles.
He got his big screen break
in 1987 is good morning.
Vietnam.
This role,
it was Adrian Cron.
Our a real life armed forces dj stationed
in Saigon and during the war it was
tailor made for Williams as manic style.
In fact,
nearly everything that he did on screen
was totally improvised the performance.
It was good enough to earn him an academy
award nomination for best actor over
the next decade.
Williams appeared in an impressive number
of films displaying a huge range and
appeal across the generations.
He Sean,
as both a dramatic and to comic actor
with his first and only Oscar coming for
best supporting actor playing a
psychologist in 1997 is good will hunting.
He had previously received two
nominations for 1988 dead poets society in
Nineteen Ninety.
One was the fisher king,
perhaps Williams's most versatile role
was one in which he never actually was on
screen,
though it was his role as the genie in
the 1992 Disney animated musical Aladdin.
The role had been
specifically written them,
although he improvised much
of the dialogue just as he
had done in good morning
Vietnam Williams.
When told to play what would be his
most beloved character in 1993 is mrs
doubtfire.
In this movie,
he portrayed a recently divorced actor
who takes on the persona of an elderly
Scottish housemate to get
closer to his children.
He spent four hours everyday putting on
his makeup to play the part while the
movie.
It was a great success.
Sunday sequel was actually in the
works at the time of Williams,
his death in 2014.
His darkest role again in 2002.
One hour.
Photo Williams played a
lonely photo technician.
He becomes obsessed with a family he
photos he has developed for years.
He received rave reviews from such
esteemed critics is then at Melton and
Abbott's.
Robin's last parents on the big screen
was in 2014 night at the museum secret of
the team in which he reprized his role
as President Theodore Roosevelt in the
2015 film.
Absolutely anything.
He provided it.
The Voice of dentists,
the dog.
It's closed out a 38 year career
that encompassed 74 movies
in 1966 together with fellow celebrity
will be Goldberg and Billy Crystal.
Robin founded Comic Relief Usa.
The PRC helps the homeless with $80
million dollars being raised as of last
year.
Together with his second wife,
he also created the windfall foundation
to help donate money to a variety of
causes including some jude
children's research hospital.
On May the 27th,
19,
55.
Robin's close friend Christopher
Reeve was thrown from a horse and it's
paralyzed.
Robin drops everything and
rushed to get his bad side.
He turns up in full costume as a crazed
Russian doctor giving rave at the first
loft.
Since it's tragic accidents,
robin would go on to donate huge sums
to research and to spinal cord injury.
When reeves died into
counseling and forth,
robin was absolutely devastated.
Williams was also passionate
about supporting the military.
He traveled and performed at many bases
around the globe and he was well known
as a modern day.
Bob Hope.
During his career,
he entertained over 100,000
troops in 13 countries.
Williams managed to quit alcohol and
cocaine in the early 19 eighties,
however,
in 2003,
he lapse back into alcohol abuse
while working on the movie,
the big white or location in
Alaska for the next three years.
He denied that he had a problem.
Finally,
he was confronted by family and friends
who convinced him to check himself into
a substance abuse rehabilitation
center in Newburg,
Oregon,
and then he finally admitted that he
was an alcoholic after 60 days in Rehab,
rather than responding to his family,
robin began living with a sober companion
who was charged with ensuring that he
didn't relapse.
It was shortly after that that his wife,
Marcy,
I left him a depressed robin,
did what he always did to get
to by when life got tough,
he threw himself into his work
going on tour to do stand up,
but unfortunately in
the middle of this tour,
it was discovered that
he needed heart surgery.
The operation,
it went well,
but it required quite at
rest in order to recuperate.
This forced time of inactivity allowed
the demons in his head to have free rein.
Williams is addictive.
Personality led to marathon
cycling and video gaming sessions.
Cycling was a healthy obsession for him,
but for a man who struggled
with depression his whole life,
the Ng alone in a room with a
computer was very dangerous.
Shortly after this,
he began drinking again.
This time we didn't care who
knew in May of 2014 Williams,
his new TV show,
the crazy ones was canceled after just
one season in July and he was back in
Rehab.
It was around that time that he also
learns that he had Parkinson's disease.
After his death,
it was discovered that what had been
diagnosed as Parkinson's was actually lewy
body dementia.
After his death,
Robin's wife Susan revealed that
Robin had been having severe runs,
prolonged episodes of fear and anxiety,
insomnia,
constipation,
stress,
and having friends that have
been going on for over a year.
She said that he would
constantly tell her,
I just want to reboot my brain.
On August the 11th,
2014,
Robin Williams committed suicide
by hanging himself with bells.
He died from asphyxiation.
His wife,
Susan,
stated that he was killed by a
terrorist and signed my husband's brain.
Within hours of the tragic
news of his passing,
thousands of fans were
posting images of themselves,
standing on their desks with the caption,
oh,
captain,
my captain in reference to Robin's
character in dead poets society.
It was a fitting tribute and to beautiful.
Stand off to this brilliant man,
so I really hope you found that
video interesting and inspiring.
If you did,
please do that.
Thumbs up button below and
don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new
videos on this channel.
Biographies of all sorts
of people from history,
whether Robin Williams to all sorts
of different things from politicians,
serial killers,
business people are running the gamut.
Anyway,
you can check out some more of those that
are over there on the right and don't
forget to subscribe.
I'm thank you for watching.